Can you believe that there is a 217-kilometer-long train track...
...at a height of 4,000 meters above the sea?
Let's go to Salta Railway Station in the Northeast of Argentina.
This could surely be a once in a lifetime ride.
This trip will take you to the desert and the remote Chilean town of Socompa.
Just imagine!
After sunset over the desert plains, the night sky will be lit up by many stars...
...and you will probably chat with other travelers.
Here are some tips for you, though.
It is better to wear something really comfortable...
...because you spend more than 16 hours on the train.
The train starts at 7 am and arrives at 11 pm.
In addition, the train ticket only includes a cup of coffee,...
...so it is better to bring your favorite food with you.
Otherwise, you would have to pay for your lunch and dinner on board.